Donald Trump's endorsement has failed
once again to get a Republican elected
in a very red state because with 51
point three percent of the vote
incumbent Democratic Louisiana Governor
John bel Edwards has been reelected
defeating the Republican challenger
Eddie risk bone or rizpah knee I'm not
exactly sure how it's pronounced winning
by roughly 40,000 votes are about 2.5
percentage points there are many reasons
why this is an interesting race we will
talk about a variety of them here number
one is that again this is a red state
this is a red state that will have a
Democratic governor now who could could
depends what happens in 2020 overlap
with a Democratic president depending on
what happens in November and might
actually be able to do some good things
and maybe move Louisiana to the left but
we will have to think about whether John
bel Edwards is actually the type of
Democrat that wants to move Louisiana to
the left and I'll get to that later but
just as importantly as we headed towards
2020 is the consideration of the Trump
effect this is another Republican in
Louisiana whose association with Trump
whose rallying with Trump whose
endorsement from Trump didn't get him
the victory even in a very red state so
we are very quickly learning that red
state governors may be worse off with
Donald Trump's endorsement which Eddy
risk Bernie had so two important things
here number one do not let Trump now
revise history by pretending that he
wasn't heavily promoting the Republican
challenger because Trump went to
Louisiana he rallied for the Republican
Trump was very involved and Trump just
lost on this one now on the other hand
it is really important and I alluded to
this before to understand that John bel
Edwards the incumbent now reelected
governor in Louisiana this is not a
progressive Democrat or even anything
remotely close to approximating a
progressive Democrat John bel Edwards is
against abortion John bel Edwards is for
more guns and more places John bel
Edwards signed a crazy restrictive
anti-abortion bill this year in
Louisiana so heinous
since winning by 2.5 percentage points
against the hit a candidate that had
Trump support is not as notable as it
would be if this were an actual
progressive because John bel Edwards is
no progressive this is about as centrist
or even right-wing as a Democrat ever
really is you we could you know talk
about Joe Manchin who's the Democratic
senator from West Virginia who is the
most conservative Democrat in the Senate
maybe John bel Edwards is even more to
the right of Joe Manchin you could
probably make a strong case of that we'd
have to look issue by issue but a loss
is a loss for Donald Trump and that's
really the issue as we go forward an
endorsement from Donald Trump support
from Donald Trump Trump rallying with
you it's not enough even to get you a
win in many red states and that could
affect not only Donald Trump in 2020 it
could might be a signal about Trump's
2020 reelection attempt but it could
also be interesting in terms of the key
Republican senators that we are trying
to push out in 2020 a few weeks ago I
told you that although I still think it
is unlikely that Democrats take the
Senate in 2020 I think is more likely in
2022 I did revise the strength of that
statement I do believe that there is a
path to Democrats taking the Senate in
2020 and one of the things that would
very much help Democrats take the Senate
in 2020 is if Donald Trump's support
becomes increasingly toxic and it will
continue to follow that the other funny
thing about this is how Republicans have
just wound themselves into a knot around
this Luiz Louisiana gubernatorial race
they were confident going in because
like I said Louisiana's very red and
before the election many of these
trumpets were saying this is going to
show you the power of Trump this win
this removal of the incumbent Democratic
governor by Eddie respin a risk pwned I
wish I knew how to pronounce it is going
to show you how Donald Trump is very
very strong his endorsement his support
they're gonna knock out the incumbent
Democratic governor they lost and now
that they lost they are pretending Trump
was never really that involved and
anyway this guy was a bad candidate it's
not Trump's fault this has nothing to do
with Trump whatsoever from flew there
and
held his crazy nationalist rallies
mostly of course to feed his own ego
they I don't know that it was really to
take out the Democratic governor it was
probably because Trump wanted to get in
front of a crowd that was once again
hand-picked brownnosers because it ended
very poorly for him when he went to the
World Series game when he went to the
UFC match he wanted one of these crazy
sycophant ik crowds but it did not
ultimately help the Republican win so
that's going to be a super interesting
narrative to follow into the 2020
elections and we will be following it
for sure let me know what you think
about this reply on youtube if you are
watching on youtube send me a tweet at
the Pakman if you are on Twitter I will
remind you on Black Friday I think or
Thanksgiving Day we are going to be
sending out an email with the last major
membership drive of 2019 if you've been
thinking about becoming a member in
supporting the show but you want to do
it at a massive discount get on our
newsletter by going to david pakman.com
many hundreds of you have done this
since I mentioned it last week sign up
and then on Thanksgiving Day or Black
Friday you will get an email which will
say this is the coupon code you were
waiting for it will be a beautiful
glorious thing that I can assure you get
on the newsletter we will take a quick
break and be back right after this a
very very busy news weekend the David
Pakman show is possible thanks to
sponsors like VIN Charo watches giving
everyone in our audience 15% off your
entire order when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch I just got a
couple of new watches from these guys
and I love them I got the Kairos limited
release gold reserve set which is very
cool I love the white face the simple
band and everything about it it's a
perfect size for my wrist really great
choice I also picked out the Ventura
bellwether
in silver and white and what I love
about this one number one the Roman
numeral at the top of the face the white
face is great this is a chronograph
model and I love the blue leather band
it's just a really nice looking watch
everybody who sees me wear this one
always asks about it
what I like about Vince Harrow as a
watch brand is you're getting quality
and you're getting a watch where it's
clear as soon as you open the box that a
lot of care and artisanship went into
the design and the way that the watch is
put together I'm not interested in
paying thousands of dollars for a watch
when I can get one that's reasonably
priced and looks just as nice and has
terrific build quality and that's
exactly what Vince Aero is in the
business of doing putting a ton of
craftsmanship into their watches making
them available for a hundred and fifty
two hundred bucks you really can't go
wrong check them out at david pakman.com
slash watch support the people who
support our show and you'll save fifteen
percent when you use that link